How you sound and what you say is
critical to communication success. Let's
put an accent on accents. My name is
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to Think
Fast, Talk Smart, the podcast.
>> [music]
>> Today I look forward to speaking once
again with my friend Valerie Friedland.
Valerie is a professor of
sociolinguistics at the University of
Nevada in Reno. She's an expert on the
relationship between language and
society. Valerie is the author of Like,
Literally, Dude, Arguing for the Good in
Bad English. And recently she released
her new book called Why We Talk Funny,
The Real Story Behind Our Accents. Well,
welcome back Valerie. I am thrilled to
be joined with you again and to continue
the conversations you and I have had
many times over the last time since you
visited. Thanks for being here. Oh,
absolutely. It's always a pleasure to
talk with you, Matt. Excellent. Shall we
get started? Let's do it.
>> You have taught me so many things about
how language works, but none has
fundamentally changed my view than what
you've talked about in terms of filled
pauses.
It totally changed the way I think about
it, I teach it, what I try to do in my
own work. For those of you who haven't
heard Valerie's complete description of
this, check out episode 91. Would you
mind just giving us a quick summary of
what filled pauses are and what they
actually do for us as communicators and
as listeners? Sure, absolutely. Well,
filled pauses are things we all use on
occasion. We all recognize because
they're the uhs and ums that populate
our pauses. And every language has them,
so it's something we find the world
over. They're not all exactly the same
form, but roughly.
But what we find is that um and uh tend
to occur when we're doing more complex
things speech-wise. So whenever we are
having more complex sentence structures,
so we're putting a lot of embeddings, a
lot of different sort of extra parts in
our sentences and ands and or uhs and
relative clauses, we find that uh and um
tend to occur before those points of
more complexity. We also find when we're
coming up with hard words, big words,
unfamiliar words, we tend to uh or um
more in front of them. But I think the
most fascinating thing is not just why
we do them as speakers because we're
kind of signaling harder work
cognitively. But it's actually what they
do for a listener that's incredible. And
I think not only do they signal to a
listener, like, "Hey, I'm I'm doing
something really complex here. It's
going to take me a minute." So they're
kind of just giving you a heads-up that
we're taking a moment. The reason we
want to do that is because if I pause
silently, you might think I'm done.
But if I uh or um, it's signaling to you
I'm not done, I'm just pausing for a
sec. But the really, really fascinating
part is that they actually really help
with memory on the listener side. So
when we run experiments and we have
people say uh before a content word,
before some sort of word that we're
interested in people remembering, and
then we run the same experiment where we
don't have people uh before that word,
we find that the recall for the word
with uh in front of it is better than in
the cases where they didn't have an uh.
Which tells us that they're actually
doing some pretty important work. So if
you want to people to remember what you
say, a little uh won't hurt you. But I
wouldn't overpopulate because we also
don't like them, so just be aware of
that facet
>> [laughter]
>> as well.
>> It's fascinating to me that that these
filler words exist across different
languages and that they actually serve a
purpose. They they they signal that
we're we're working hard. They highlight
that what we're about to say is
something you should pay attention to.
And it turns out people actually do pay
more attention and they actually
remember that information more. So the
old adage, "Get rid of all the filler
pauses," is not actually accurate. We we
we it's okay to have them and they in
fact help us. It's when you have a lot
of them that it gets distracting. And I
would argue that that my theory is the
reason when somebody uses so many of
these filled pauses annoys us is we're
we're actually trained to expect
something of value to follow. And if all
that follows an um is another um, that
actually is frustrating. Harshly, I
think that's true. I also think it's
that, you know, the natural tendency is
that we're going to um and uh more often
in high-stakes contexts because it's
things we're not as used to saying. And
it's not necessarily it's not anxiety or
stress. There's actually not that much
evidence that that really increases our
rate of umming and uhing. It's because
we're saying things that are less
familiar. When we go in front of, you
know, the executive leadership and we're
talking about something very important
that we've done, we're probably going to
be use higher-level vocabulary. So I
think when we're hearing presentations
or speeches and people do a lot of
umming and uhing, that is something that
annoys us because we have an expectation
that they're they're very well prepared
and they know what they're going to say.
So things that signal they don't disturb
us.
I think you're exactly right. I'd like
to turn our attention now to your second
book, which is all about accents.
You write that we all have accents. Why
do we so easily notice accents in others
but not ourselves? I think the greatest
myth that we operate under every day is
that we don't have an accent. You know,
we don't notice our accents because
everybody around us generally talks like
we do. So if you are moving to a new
place, that's really when you're first
realizing, "Oh my gosh, I'm the one that
sounds funny." Because when you are the
one that is sort of the dominant speaker
in an area, most people are sounding
like you, so you don't hear it. You're
used to it. Particularly when we're
children we grow up in an area, we we
kind of adjust or normalize to whatever
we hear most often around us. Which can
also be not just the accent that's sort
of prevalent in your area, but say
you're born to a non-native speaker and
you you grew up as a native speaker in,
you know, the US for example, you won't
hear your parents' accent because you
have normalized them as as children. So
when people come into our communities
and they're not dressing like we are,
they're not looking like we are, and
really strongly not sounding like we
are,
we notice that and that's where the sort
of the salience of accent comes in. I do
want to talk about culture because
accents and cultures go together. When
communicating across cultures, we often
focus on learning the right vocabulary,
the grammar. But you highlight the
rhythm and intonation,
like English as a stress-timed language
versus Spanish or Mandarin Mandarin
being a syllable-timed. I'd like for you
to explain those. Are are huge hurdles
for people. How do these, what are
called prosodic differences, affect how
well speakers are understood and
evaluated by somebody in the native
language they're now speaking?
Absolutely. When we're learning a
language, a language that's not our
native language, we work a lot on
sounds, but we really tend to ignore
some really important areas that make a
big impact on how comprehensible you are
and how intelligible you are as a
speaker, which is an area that linguists
call prosodic features or prosody. And
those include things like stress, word
stress, and sentence stress. So what's
highlighted by a speaker in a language,
uh tone, which can be like with
Mandarin, tone on a single word can, you
know, actually change the meaning of
that word, something English doesn't
have, which is obviously something
really hard for English speakers when
they're learning Mandarin, or intonation
patterns, which refer to things like
when as an English speaker I'm getting
to the end of my sentence, I often go
down in my tone at the end of a sentence
to signal I'm done talking. Conversely,
when I have a question, I often ask that
question with a rising intonation
because that's signaling that I'm asking
a question. So that's sort of a
sentence-level pattern. So those are
different types of prosodic features and
they're very difficult to learn when you
come in from a language with one system
prosodically and you're learning a
language with a different system
prosodically. So for example, as I
mentioned a minute ago, an English
speaker trying to learn a tonal
language.
Our intonation patterns, where we go up
at the end or down at the end, make it
really hard when we're trying to get
tones on a word. The opposite is when we
have different sort of structures to our
language inherently, and and that's
where we get to the stress versus
syllable timing, where our fundamental
way that we stress syllables in our
language is different than another one.
So let's break that down. So stress
timing is a language like English,
Russian, Arabic, German. And this is
where particular words or syllables that
you're you're speaking get more stressed
than others depending on what the
speaker wants to highlight in that
language. So certain syllables are
louder and longer, and then the little
syllables in between or the other
syllables in between actually get
squished together because they have to
be said more rapidly to fit into sort of
a certain timing unit between those
stressed syllables. So in that language
you have in those languages you have
sort of
rhythm that's sort of like
right? So you have the short syllables
that are really jam-packed and that's
why you get things like vowel reduction.
So when I say the instead of thee in
English or
uh instead of a, it's because I'm
actually having to squish them between
stressed syllables in a while. In a
syllable-timed
which is something like Spanish or
Chinese or French or Portuguese, every
syllable has equal stress. So, it's more
like bum bum bum bum bum bum bum of a
rhythm. Now, this seems very complex and
and you know, like how would I ever
figure out how to switch over? Well,
exactly. That's exactly the problem. We
don't get practice in that. This
completely impacts how you well you're
understood. It may not seem like that
big a deal cuz it just is rhythmic, but
it it's huge deal because think of a
word like What's Let me say the word as
someone who might have a syllable timed
language. Uh
it'd be elefe, elephant, elephant.
Well, if you didn't know we were talking
about giant things with big ears and
trunks, you might have no idea what I
said because it's elephant in for a
native English speaker because their
stress I'm stressing that first syllable
and then jamming the others really
quick. But if I have a stress syllable
timed language, I'm going to stress each
syllable equally and I'll have no uh
vowel because that's only happens when I
remove stress from a syllable. So, what
happens you can actually get words that
are completely unintelligible because
you're saying the stress wrong.
Because you used a syllable timed
pattern on a stress timed language. So,
long story short, these are things that
are really rarely discussed in language
classes. They're often problems that
people encounter and they don't know why
they're having problems being
understood. And in fact, research
suggests that non-native patterns like
this can if in fact intelligibility as
much as not being able to pronounce the
sounds correctly.
Now, a solution is it's not you know,
there's no easy magic fix, but the
solution is really practice, practice,
practice. And a lot of that is generally
shadowing native speakers. And you
shadow them it can be you know,
something you've recorded. It doesn't
have to be interactive, although that
helps if you can work with someone. But
you could even record a TV show and
repeat exactly in the intonation pattern
of that television show. Eventually,
you'll start getting that rhythm down.
So, there's no easy solution, but there
is a solution. And unfortunately, we
don't teach that a lot in language
classes. So, what I'm hearing you say,
which is super important for people who
are trying to learn a second language.
Yes, vocabulary and grammar are
important, but what's as important and
and perhaps even more in some cases for
intelligibility, it is understanding the
rhythm, the the stress patterns. And And
as with everything communication
related, it's one thing to understand it
intellectually, it's another thing to do
it. And that's really a a way to help
yourself. I appreciate you identifying
that.
I want to switch the sides of the
equation. We often think of the burden
of successful communication as being on
the speaker, the the non-native speaker
producing the information. What role
does the listener play in this
communicative dynamic? And how can we
train our ears and minds to be better
able to adapt to understanding
unfamiliar accents? We often really put
a lot of the burden on a non-native
speaker anytime we're having a
conversation. We have this expectation
that the speaker it's their job to make
it intelligible to us. It's their job to
make their speech understood. And and
there's there so many different problems
with that equation, but let's unpack it
a little bit in terms of of why that's
not the case.
First of all, communication's a
partnership, right? It's just like a
marriage. You can't have a marriage when
one side is doing all the work. And you
can't have a conversation where one
side's doing all the work. If you've
ever had a conversation where it's only
one sided, it's not a good conversation
and you probably aren't going to keep
talking to that person, right? So, if we
want to make communication successful,
we have to go into it with this
understanding that it's not just their
job as a speaker, it's my job as a
listener to make this productive and
successful. There are a couple things at
play. One is as a listener, I don't
realize sometimes that
they're not just speaking with an
accent. I'm hearing with an accent. And
we really put this
belief system around accent on speakers
alone. But we don't listen without a
bias that is shaped by our own language
and accent experience. I mean, that is
why language is hard for us to learn.
It's because of our personal experience
as a child growing up in a certain
language system. And this affects us in
a number of ways. One thing is it it
makes it harder to understand what
sounds they might be saying because we
have an expectation about what they're
supposed to sound like. And maybe
they're not sounding that way. But two,
we also have a role the brain plays in
making people better or worse
understood. So, simply by being
accustomed to hearing a certain kind of
speech and having expectations going
into a conversation about what we think
someone will sound like. So, say they
look like they'll speak with an American
accent, but then it turns out they start
speaking with a French accent. That
actually causes cognitive disruption for
us. And I don't mean that in a negative
way. I simply mean there's an effect on
the brain of this additional processing
burden that hearing something unexpected
or unfamiliar places on us. So, there's
a bunch of different aspects in terms of
why we're hearing with an accent. You
know, I think the long story short of
that is to recognize that part of the
reason we're not understanding has
nothing to do with them and everything
to do with us. And there's often a power
dynamic at play that we ignore when
we're talking about communication across
different accents. There's a power
dynamic that puts whoever is dominant in
that sort of social or institutional
setting in a position where they feel
that it's the other person's job to make
sure that they're they're coming across
clearly and intelligibly. But that's an
impossible task when you are not willing
to meet them halfway.
So, as both listeners and speakers, we
need to both accept our roles and our
jobs and our faults in speaking and
listening to contribute to getting to a
place where we can better understand
each other. One simple option for that
as a listener is if we know to expect
something unexpected, that knowledge
alone decreases the processing burden.
So, simply going in with an open mind,
right? Where we're thinking, I don't
know what this person Just cuz they look
like something doesn't tell me anything
about how they're going to sound. So,
being more open in our expectations
actually mitigates this effect on our
brain. But also, the more accents we
hear around us, so diversity in our
institutions, diversity in our friend
group, the less unfamiliar accents sound
to us, the better jobs our brains do
more generally. So, those are easy
things to do. Be more friends with more
people. Be more open in your
expectations. Those are not hard things.
They seem to be hard for us as humans,
but they shouldn't be. So, I think
there's really a two-sided view we can
take on on communication and that's it's
a partnership, not a one-sided event.
Amen. Communi-
>> [laughter]
>> Communication takes two, right? And we
often focus on the producing of the
information, but the receiving of it is
critically important. The idea about
processing fluency and cognitive load
are really important and and it's not
just with accents. It's when you're
talking about technical content, you're
doing the same thing. You're increasing
cognitive load and processing. So, the
some of the same advice holds true. Uh
if you're a listener, have an open mind.
I like this idea of of exposing yourself
to diverse accents and ideas. That helps
reduce the processing fluency and
burden. I am I really again, you always
stir things up in me and get me thinking
differently. I've often thought about
speaking accents. I've never thought
about listening accents. And that's a
really
insightful way of of thinking about
this.
Valerie, I knew this was going to be
fantastic. You know that when we end, I
always ask three questions. One I make
up just for you and two I make I been
consistent across all the episodes. Are
are you up for answering these
questions? Let's do it. I love it. Yes.
Excellent. So, if you could give just
one bit of advice to somebody who's
speaking a language that's not their own
and has an accent, what would that be?
The biggest advice I can tell you is
that not to put so much pressure on
yourself to sound like a native speaker.
We have this weird ideal of what it
means to learn another language, what it
means to be fluent in that language,
what it means to be successful in that
language. And it's an unrealistic goal
and it causes all sorts of problems for
native speakers and non-native speakers
alike. So, as I'm I'm entering this new
journey of a language, what my goal
should be is being successful at having
communicative you know, partnerships.
That's really what we want to do. It
shouldn't be I want to sound like I
don't have an accent. What we need to do
is embrace accents because they're
beautiful and they tell us our history.
And they also tell us where we come from
and our identities. And we should never
want to get rid of that. Instead, focus
on what helps me be more
easily understood and more confident as
a speaker because that is what will make
you successful. So, you know, you can
communicate very well with an accent. We
just need to start believing that more
as a as a speaker of a non-native with a
non-native variety. So, it's really
about mindset. It's it's realize that
you can be a very effective communicator
even though you're speaking a language
that's not your own and you might have
an accent for those listening. And and
it's the goal is not to sound like a
native speaker. The goal is to be
successful in the communication and that
focus shift can help. The advice I
always give people is when you introduce
yourself, don't start with your name. As
you alluded to, we're very good at at
digesting accents, but when something
important is said at the
right at the beginning, our brain is
still adjusting to, oh, that's how that
person sounds. So, I often encourage
people who have accents to start by
saying something else first before their
name. Maybe I'm really excited to be
here or I'm somebody who's very
passionate about this, and then say your
name, so that people have uh started to
adjust and adapt to your accent. So,
hopefully those two bits of advice can
help people. Question number two, uh who
is a communicator that you admire and
why?
>> I would say that one person I really
admire as a communicator in the same
sort of space as me, the science
communication, is Adam Grant. I think he
doesn't have an accent, but he does a
remarkable job of communicating really
really sort of technical uh
research-based information in a way
that's both relevant and very accessible
to everyday speakers. Question number
three, what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe? I don't think it's
going to surprise you that I start with
listening because we've talked so much
about that and I think we often just
worry when we go into a conversation
about speaking, but we really should
worry about is listening for so many
reasons. One is that makes us better at
as a communicator because we're
genuinely paying attention and doing
some work as a as a listener because
it's important that we do that, but also
because it helps shape how we respond.
And a lot of times that we spend too
much time worrying and I think
non-native speakers sometimes do this
about what we're going to say, we
actually miss really important nuanced
points where we can make connections
because of what they said. So, I think
listener is listenership is really
really important. The other is
self-awareness and and this is different
than worrying about how I'm sounding.
This is about understanding that my own
background brings me to every
conversation with preconceived notions
of how things should go and what people
should sound like. And as we talked
about, this influences the way that we
process things. So, just being aware of
that really can reshape our interactions
with people.
And then the third is smile, be
friendly, be open. I think sometimes
we're so
sort of set on presenting ourselves a
certain way or being a certain way in a
context professionally particularly,
where we forget that just being friendly
and kind and and open
can actually open a lot of doors for us.
It can be the best um nurturing sort of
piece of the puzzle for a good
conversation is when someone feels like
you really want to genuinely have a good
conversation with them, that you're
happy to be there talking with them. I
think that makes them more interested in
conversing with you as well.
That last part is so important. It's
really about connection and regardless
of if you have an accent or not, you
connect. I like your point on listening
as well.
Thank you for connecting with us and for
sharing your insights on the value and
importance of accents and really
reflecting on ways that if we have an
accent that we can address it, as well
as those of us who are communicating
with people who have accents. As always,
Valerie, I learned so much from you. I
appreciate your energy, your insights,
and your time today. Thank you.
Always a good conversation with you,
Matt. Thanks.
>> [music]